[Musique]
lima cette émission d' espace
autochtones où nous allons aujourd'hui
réfléchir à comment
et là j'avais écrit dans mon texte
comment redonner confiance aux
autochtones envers le système de santé
et je me suis dit non comment donner la
confiance parce qu'on peut leur donner
c'est ce dont on va réfléchir avec mes
trois invités alors je vous les présente
on va commencer dans le carré à droite
jennifer brazeau la directrice générale
du centre d'amitié autochtone de
lanaudière vous êtes installé à joliette
jennifer bonjour oui bonjour bonjour
également là sous moi donc dans le coin
gauche en bad choeur pascal braud vous
appartenez au gmf universitaire de
lanaudière vous aussi vous êtes installé
à joliette bonjour bonjour
et puis dans le coin droit mais en bas
on se croirait sur sur sur une patinoire
où je sais pas trop quoi on a l'air de
parler du monde sportif aujourd'hui mais
c'est pas le cas
le grand chef du conseil des attikameks
monsieur constant haschich devant un
chef awashish bonjour alors donc oui ma
question de base c'était comment donner
ou redonner confiance aux autochtones
dans le système de soins de santé
tout ça commence avec le décès de joyce
et chaque coin c'était il ya un mois
déjà et là j'aimerais savoir qu'est ce
qui s'est passé depuis un mois
exactement à ce qu'on sent que les
choses bougent qu'ils aient envie de se
lancer pour répondre à cette question
peut-être le grand chef à washington ce
que vous avez eu l'occasion de
rencontrer le nouveau ministre des
affaires autochtones donc peut-être que
vous auriez déjà une idée de ce qui
bouge en moins dans le monde politique
ah c'est sûr que la joyce et chaque one
pourquoi laisser l'un
beaucoup de réactions évidemment côté
des premières nations mais également la
population non autochtone également les
éliminer ces allées gouvernement n'ont
donc rejoint n'ont plus le choix de dans
un sens mais non sa voix si c'est dans
le bon sens je pense la tvh au poids
musée mais je sais qu'il ya des choses
qui bougent la première j'ai parlé à
tous d'horizons et de le mettre en place
comme un plan d'action spécifique pour
la 9ème également un ensemble ce qui est
fait il savait très forts à ce jeu c'est
qui qui raconte les hommes à la racine
de trouver une façon de faire bouger des
choses que je trouve ça correct qui
pouvaient être impliquées à tous niveaux
des cieux je sais que les instruments
ils font parler d'eux au texas au volley
au saguenay que ça soit en mauricie que
ce soit dans lanaudière ont noté que des
contacts comme je demande ce matin la
semaine passée en une accro de becker
ici simplement ici justement pouvoir
recommancer des choses à améliorer dans
cette région si je sais que lui depuis
12 ans 3 e mc2 maintenant place à
l'action
l'accusation culturelle et une
explication et de donner sa mère qu'à ce
prix que ça va amener obama
qu'est ce qui serait un grand buffon ou
un grillon redoubler d'efforts et je
pense à ce niveau de leschaux change
rien
à vos plats sont d'ailleurs également
change des autochtones envoie des mots
c'est ce que c'est pas toujours positive
il ya des gens encore aujourd'hui les
mêmes les il accepte et d'une puce or
toutes les aides est bonne autant que
les mauvaises sortent les premières
nations et un moment donné je suis gay
vaincu marc être coulés les groupes que
des gens aient pu qui se relève et
collectifs louisien confiance que tu as
des premières nations ne sont pas au
[Musique]
niveau social au niveau des institutions
également nouveau s'ouvrir la main il ya
des choses qui se passent et c'est à
nous y amène tout le monde les
organisations autochtones et la présence
de tous les élus autochtone de travail
et de s'assurer yann de prince tu me
laisses de s'assurer qu'un léger que
notre message passe bien ou pour des
organisations de lui qu'est ce que nous
on vit puissent être prises en compte
dans l'édition de l'e3 coach compte elle
développe une harley les prochains jours
ou prochaines semaines
d'ailleurs nous est revenue elle n'a
jamais l'initiative de cause et de manon
un aïeul qui travaille comme avant
l'échéance et stayers n'oubliez pas
raccord des commentaires suggestions la
gamme en place jusqu'aux os 9 pouces
qu'on avait planifié de main ferme et
soeur aînée principe ouvrir grands
atouts que des organisations qui
justement alors si ça jusqu'au 9
novembre
c'est quoi exactement le principe de
joyce là bas c'est bien c'est de
développer et d des principes de base
qu'elle est ou dans les établissements
établissement médical les les autres
professionnels le gouvernement les des
employés système de santé aux dates où
l'information sur la connaissance et que
dans son pays
qui peut savoir une barre besoins
minimum de connaissances et condamnation
mais une pose également respecter caen
vient de donner des soins de santé
auprès nation du ski c'est ce qui
inquiète avant de se dessiner
présentement on avait des jeux syrie les
garder mais ces actes peuvent en avoir
plus de trois mois - qui ça va dépendre
de toutes les façons fénay
d'accumulation des lions maraval vu des
très bons commentaires des
professionnels des commandes à l'heure
où les canadiens ont eu des commentaires
d'ordre confessionnel
le regroupement de gouaille et du
beaucoup de bons coureurs maintenant
votre jambon oeuf normal c'est l'objet
qui concerne est terminée je vous vois
réagir pascal est ce que vous avez été
est ce que le principe de jungle
connaissait vous l'avez suivi
est-ce que vous même vous pouvez donner
des recommandations à l'intérieur de ce
document là ben moi je travaillais avec
mes équipes justement parce que je pense
que ce principe ne peut être extrêmement
porteur pour que quelque chose de bon
sorte de cette tragédie là dans la
mesure où tu abandonnes ça nous donne
une grille d'amaris commune quand on
doit maintenant regarder ces enjeux le
salon réservé beaucoup plus tôt en fait
pied dans un monde idéal de m
malheureusement il ya une femme qui a
payé de sa vie qui maintenant devient
peu l'image qui doivent nous revenir en
tête à chaque fois moi je suis un jeu
fait je fais d'enseignement médical je
suis archi à l'université laval en
enseignement chef des soins aux patients
des premières nations aux atikamekw de
manawan entre autres cette grille de
marisela ellis elle est porteuse hamon
d'une force extrêmement importante qui
est celle que quand on veut réfléchir à
l'organisation que ce soit de
l'enseignement ça on ne doit plus jamais
le faire sans la participation des
premiers intéressés leur voix doit
primer il doit être présente
il faut travailler avec eux à
décoloniser la formation des médecins ça
des médecins et des professionnels de la
santé en général à s'assurer de leur
représentation devant toutes les
instances de pouvoir parce que c'est
comme ça que les angles morts arrivent
c'est quand les gens concernés sont pas
autour de la table pics ce qu'on voit
avec des grosses machines comme nos
organisations leurs six entre autres
c'est que les gens qui sont
particulièrement dans des positions
vulnérabilité on peut leur voix
facilement représenter autour de la
table et là je pense qu'avec la tragédie
qui est arrivé à joyce et chaque coin
langlois on le voit qui il est
intolérable que c'est un accident
catastrophique sais pas c'est pas une
personne c'est toute une toute une
nation c'est tout un groupe de personnes
qui faisaient membre depuis peu plus ne
plus voir on aurait dû franchement c'est
un décès qui auraient jamais dû arriver
à mon avis est là maintenant ben salah
cette réalité là elle a un nom et j'ose
croire que la force
vous venez rire de l'eau c'est à dire
que maintenant qu'on sait que c'est
c'est que s'est personnifié
mais plus personne va pouvoir les demies
puis on va pouvoir avancer
mais le principe de joyce moi je le vois
dans mon travail quotidien comme quelque
chose qui veut constamment me rappeler
quand je conçois du matériel
d'enseignement
quand je travaille quand je développe
d'une belle jour 2 et où est ce que tu
es en train de faire sur youtube puis
qui est ce que tu représentes vraiment
en faisant ce qu'ils de m'assurer que
les principaux intéressés sont autour de
la tâche parce que jamais développer
quelque chose sans heurt finalement
qu'il principe de jazz band c'est sûr
que ça vient rappeler encore à mon sens
à moi dans la manière dont je le conçois
qui avec les représentations que j'ai
fait aux pies mes collègues c'est
partager avec nous on a déposé des on a
déposé un mémoire pour la consultation
publique
on a fait des représentations près de
dole qui je crois que nos voix - poteau
dans la même dans la même direction se
profile ce brassage d'idées la surface
par les principaux intéressés justement
mais moi je veux juste dire que pour
notre contribution on est
prêt à se mettre dans cette position des
couleurs et qu'on va aller on est prêt à
aller très loin
parce que justement le caractère
systémique de ceux ci comporte tout un
peu cette responsabilité le fait qu on
fait partie problème manche on peut
faire partie de la solution ou si on en
prend conscience oui jennifer avec le
son des mises autochtone de lanaudière
est ce que vous avez participé justement
à la mise en place de ce principe de
jazz est ce que vous y avez collaboré
également qu'est ce qui serait important
de retrouver dans ce document où nous
ont comme un papa tu es à la conception
où les recommandations par contre on a
fait la promotion auprès nos membres de
cette consultation ne sais pas moi je
suis quand même une fille assez pratique
moi quand je vois après un mois
qu'est ce qui s'était passé je vois
beaucoup de mobilisation communautaire
comme avec le principe de juristes que
je trouve me donne au moins l'espoir
qu'on va continuer à travailler sur cet
enjeu là on va continuer à avancer mais
en même temps j'attends encore voir les
résultats concrets so intérim de comment
ça va vraiment changer pour la réalité
des autochtones en milieu urbain qui a
les autochtones qui s'en vont vers les
services de santé
m je vous vois pas encore le sentiment
d'urgence
localement au sein du site de réagir
concrètement pour faire des changements
s'est passé pour moi alors deux je pense
qu'il ya quand même beaucoup travaillé à
faire pour pouvoir réellement changé la
mt qu'on demande c'est fait face à que
j'atteins provost mais j'ai quand même
rapport mais vous jennifer vous avez
décidé d'agir rapidement en fait là elle
ne travaille vous le faisiez déjà en
amont vous avez ouvert cette semaine une
clinique au sens d'amitié autochtone de
lanaudière donc il ya un médecin qui
vient c'est quoi deux fois par mois qui
vient rencontrer des gens sur place des
attikameks parce que votre d'amitié
autochtone et fréquenté principalement
par des attikameks
donc ça vous l'aviez déjà commencé est
ce que vous l'avez bousculer avec tout
ce qui s'est passé depuis un mois une
ouverture cet unique au mouzon c'est
quelque chose qu'on travaillait pendant
des années en fait c'était un stérilité
qui était conçu plus que 50 qui dans les
dernières mois avant le décès de jobs et
son coup c'est vraiment pour essayer de
faire réaliser ce projet leur le plus
vite possible parce que on sait à chaque
jour j'entends des histoires des gens
qui ont vécu c'est du racisme ou d'un
sentiment d'inconfort envers les
services alors on a essayé de mettre la
pression en juin j'ai eu une rencontre
avec le pdg cas où est ce qu'on va
essayer de développer d'avoir un des
ressources ont cinq six ont pouvoir
réaliser ce qu'ils n'éclairent amis en
fait qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec le
décès de jobs on a quand même sérieux
d'outreau qui est un allié qui est
amenée à l'or a aussi permis un espace
et un médecin qui appartient au même
groupe de médecine familiale que vous
pascal 600 voix on travaille ensemble
qu'ils avaient quand même ouverture qui
on s'est dit qu'à deux on va le faire
réaliser parce qu'il ya quand même un
besoin criant en ce moment qui dit va
mener son sac qui ont fait acheter une
table de massage qui on a on a des
bénévoles qui ont montré des mureaux
puis en avoir le coeur net
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis un
mois pour par exemple pour les
attikameks de la communauté de manouane
joyce et chaque one est décédé mais plus
personne qui a envie d'aller dans cet
hôpital là et on peut le comprendre
est ce que tout le monde maintenant va
se diriger vers le centre d'amitié
autochtone en sachant qu'ils aient une
clinique qui a été monté là en fait
c'est pas suffisant comme comme besoin
actuellement
[Musique]
non c'est pas suffisant de ses deux
visites de cliniques par mois ça ne
prendrait pas aux besoins
qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est on à
l'accompagnement aussi à des références
où les membres qui peuvent pas
nécessairement
être en excès de ses chroniqueurs parce
que sinon ce qui est débordée puis on a
fait de voir les personnes qu'ils sont
vraiment trop éloigné du système qu'il
faut de l'axé des poteaux
comment conclure ligne ou des indics les
rejoindre avec le médecin qui s'est le
mieux comprendre comment on peut
continuer à essayer de de soutenir la
communauté le plus précis qu'on peut
tous y de dénoncer des cas de
discrimination grand voile est-ce que
vous en avez encore beaucoup parlé il ya
un un monde s'est déroulée nous en tant
que journaliste on entendu beaucoup de
témoignages avait énormément de gens qui
voulaient parvis qui voulait s'exprimer
pas seulement concernant des hôpitaux
l'hôpital de joliette parce que la
réalité elle est partout dans d'autres
hôpitaux à travers le québec elle touche
d'où notre nation également alors est ce
que est ce qu on a senti que dans ces
hôpitaux là un peu partout au québec
il y avait des changements qui
s'amorçait pascal est ce que vous avez
vu les changements réels
je sais pas ses potes dans les hôpitaux
que j'ai vu les changements c'est dans
les dans les yeux que les cartes ce sont
vers deux collègues qui se sont le
décident de just say la médiane
la médiatisation qui est une auto il ya
énormément de gens qui ont comme réalisé
que ça arrive et puis que ça se passait
alors que était pas du tout comment
simple il faut voir que dans cette
inconscience la vie c'est pas
nécessairement un aveuglement volontaire
les gens libres ou des services dans le
système pompiers ont l'impression bien
faire mais le système est fait de
manière cruelle quand on parle de
racisme systémique on est un peu dans
cette dimension là les systèmes offrent
souvent sa propre logique qui écrase les
hindous syllabes
ce qui fait que la machine rouler rouler
roulent à yap ashlyn tout va bien on se
questionne pas sur le fait que c'est
parce que les gens se reconnaissent pas
dans les mécanismes qui sont en place
qui n'ont pas conscience que ces
mécanismes là à cause de la nature de ce
qu'ils ont vécu vont être capables de
porter des solutions alors on se dit
baye a pas de plan il ya pas deux
statistiques ça n'existe pas mais moi ce
que j'ai vu qui j'ai énormément de
collègues sont venus me parler et puis
qui m'ont dit mais qu'est ce que je peux
faire
je m'identifie à certaines choses qui
ont été nommés puis je réalise que j'ai
marché ou au contraire je veux
m'améliorer fait ça c'est quelque chose
qui est empreint tangible probablement
quand on est à l'extérieur de la machine
de soins c'est pas évident c'est pas
genre de chose qui fait des médias mais
ce changement dans l'ouverture de
beaucoup de professionnels de la santé
moi c'est quelque chose que je ne
servais pas que ça fait depuis 2015 que
je travaille quand même sur ces sujets
jeunes et que le refus des mois ça va
avoir pris je dois tragique pour y
arriver mais là on ne les
transformations du système vont devoir
se faire une reconnaissance importante
qui doit venir du fait du caractère
systématique de la problématique soit
c'est une chose mais il faut il faut pas
d'un côté celles traitées système peut
négliger les individus qui sont devant
parce que je pense qu'une partie du
changement on va être capable de le
faire en travaillant en collègues en
mettant des patients des témoignages de
patients directement dans les oreilles
des médecins directement dans les
oreilles des infirmiers et des
infirmières
on va être capable de créer cette
tempête loupé cette écoute le pied c'est
juste à mon échelle ce soir mais moi je
les entends sait comment parler puis
j'ai des collègues qui me disent à quel
point maintenant ils souffrent de cette
étiquette de se dire mon dieu je fais
partie de ce système le qu'est-ce que je
peux faire j'ai une collègue qui m'a
appelé en catastrophe parce que une de
ses patientes lui a dit écoute moi je
veux plus être traités dans son hôpital
toi tu es dans cet hôpital
moi je veux je vais être soigné à lyon
puis elle avait la possibilité pour
différentes raisons de l'être
et elle sait plus à qui j'ai énormément
parce qu'ils aiment et on avait une
bonne relation ensemble qui en ressent
l'institution dans laquelle je suis ben
non match par la relation avec ma
passion du christ aime façon qu'ils
s'entendaient très bien le fait qu il
derrière les systèmes il ya des humains
qui loge partie 4 comme moi où je
souhaite non coupable il travaille c'est
oui une bonne organisation au niveau des
soins qu'ils savent obstacle face le
meilleur levier
j'y crois qu'en mangeant sur wii on
parle beaucoup du système vous avez
parlé de racisme systémique pourtant au
gouvernement
on ne reconnaît pas encore le racisme
systémique est alors constant si on veut
que les choses changent
mais si le gouvernement ne reconnaît pas
qu'il y à du racisme systémique mais que
le fit le système ne fonctionne pas
comment on va agir comment va
fonctionner comment vous vous êtes
capable de fonctionner de converser avec
un gouvernement qui à la base ne
reconnaît pas que le système ne
fonctionne peut-être pas très bien c'est
tout
c'est tout une joute lucky qui commence
pour nous le ton me développe par les
opérations ne doive fait beaucoup de
représentations à ce sens de plusieurs
reprises que ce soit moi ou mais ceux
qui sont devant moi
ces positions de tombouctou par lh2 pour
le maître section d'un système que les
gagner ce thème qui est critiquée des
tristes événements québec voudra
connaître et c'est la commission qui est
qu'il avait envie de travailler si on ne
cible pas la terre on revivre avec les
gens est ce qu'on veut la même
appréhension pour que les choses
changent
une barre de 1,10 par action
quand vous faut payer les jo le guen
pierre et entraînant des changements qui
explique qu'ils voient et douloureuse de
changement à l'internaute est d'aider
des établissements c'est comme cela que
les gens allaient note originale
ce contrat la problématique toujours
qu'ils aient quitté pour un risque
systémique c'est quelque chose à part et
qui crée le racisme c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on renvoie si jeune c'est une loi qui
du coup été contrainte à l'abandon dans
la création de cette confédération
enveloppe système et par conséquent les
fondateurs du canada on peut croire en
période de campagne les gens comme et
esclavage nous on compare également
convenu de fuir un ou deux fois
vous ne devez pas céder humide ce que
nous on ne vit pas comme d'hab donne ici
au québec au canada les grands ballets
canadiens français
c'est vrai que ou sinon plus facile à
une certaine période allait ajuster leur
logique quand je voulais le moulage sous
québec
mais là c'est totalement différent au
moins l'un des deux fondateurs de cette
confédération canadienne du rhône a été
quand après un intérêt qui me comté où
nous pour mieux exploiter territoire au
lieu d'être des ressources naturelles
mais on est soixante cinq arrières audy
goudeseune se soucier du résultat de la
ccspb de résultats de loi de police et
que des mises en place dont des brumes à
ostrava
[Musique]
l'élève de concrétiser c'est un camion
qui sont à sarm étant donné qu'on était
un groupe est très ciblé des premiers
matchs du canada et de des politiques et
les lois qui entérinera la confédération
il ya deux coeurs de l'inter ne s'est
pas les tribunaux il m'a beaucoup
d'organes partie des ministres à québec
c'est une rihanna du couple vivant
vauban alors si on veut que les choses
changent rapidement on va pas se tourner
vers le gouvernement parce que c'est
toujours beaucoup plus lent on le voit
les le rapport de la commission vient il
sorti il ya des jeunes maintenant treize
mois est bien vu beaucoup de
recommandations qui parlait justement du
système de santé chez les autochtones
qu'on devait régler et on voit que les
choses ne bougent vraiment pas
rapidement d'ailleurs à quel point on
s'est rendu compte que le directeur
général du cices de lanaudière n'était
même pas au courant des problèmes qui
avait dans son hôpital principal
acial quand vous avez découvert sein de
votre côté que daniel castonguay le
grand pdg n'était même pas au courant de
la réalité de son hôpital alors que vous
va coûter voulu vous l'avez vue d'une
certaine manière mais sans constater
l'ampleur finalement du problème
pourtant quand vous enseigner à
l'université vous enseigner cette
sécurisation la culture elle vous en
parlez de sécurisation culturel mais
quand vous voyez que d'un niveau à
l'autre il ya une méconnaissance
incroyable comment vous réagissez à tout
ça ben la question à l'époque parce que
le problème est tellement vaste où est
le problème les vastes je pense que
madame éclairage intéressant de le
dompter le parallèle avec la roma
commence je vais le laisser commenter là
dessus il brièvement simplement pour
rappeler dans mon côté
les changements j'essaie de les faire un
peu à l'échelle ou est-ce que moi c'est
des grosses machines les six bien sûr
que tu penses que politiquement on avait
des questions à se poser sur excuse
c'est jean d'administration en termes de
grosses sommes
lourdeur cover qui a la souplesse pour
répondre aux problèmes des gens qui sont
particulièrement dans des situations de
marginalité avérée ou que le contexte de
vie met dans des situations de
marginalité ou de vulnérabilité
potentielle
ça c'est autre chose qui est
présentement on a une belle illustration
du fait que c'est des gros gros gros
organe qui son portrait qui viennent
dont la tête et le coeur sont
probablement très loin si je peux au
final je pense qu'on a on a une belle
illustration d'une question beaucoup
plus large qu'on doit se poser et moi
j'espère que justement des gens comme
adam braz où le travail qu'ils font pas
le travail de représentation constant
qui font bien on va peut-être être
capable de votre structure capable de
porter plus des coups de pieds d'actions
en lien avec ce fait que je vais laisser
madame travaux pour commenter jennifer
mais je vais essayer de me remettre dans
la conversation était quand même assez
de denrées seront transformés par louis
par contre je pense qu'on a plus qu
est-ce que c'est sorti dans les
nouvelles récemment avec la réaction du
pdg qui expliqué qu'ils n'étaient pas au
courant
le quai ce qui se passait au moi je
trouve ça quand même étonnant étant
donné que ya plusieurs membres de la
communauté qui ont essayé de faire
[Musique]
entendre leur seller en jeu auprès du
pdg
je suis sûr que manouane les autres
problèmes en contact et entreprises
on est plein plein de témoignages des
membres qui ont fait des clubs qui ont
témoigné à travers la commission qui le
pdg a désigné un représentant pour aller
participer à la commission lui qui a pas
pris la peine pour faire un suivi après
avoir jeté quoi les résultats de sept de
ses peines
témoin commission là moi ça me dit que
cette époque priorité pour lui alors
piégés des gros qu'incidemment de caisse
qui devrait peser comme acquis ça
devrait gérer cette situation là parce
que moi en tant que gestionnaire s'il y
avait tellement un grand dangereux qui
se déroulait dans mon roman ou un
organisme qui jetait mais pas au courant
je pense qu'il y aurait dû questions sur
mon psy je devrais avoir maggia alors je
pense aussi que le sénat c'est quelque
chose qu'ils font beaucoup de au côté
politique faire savoir les besoins que
les enjeux là dit il le fait qu'ils
n'ont pas écouté aucune instance amis
moi je trouve ça vraiment désolant
constance que vous étiez en contact oui
avec avec le pdg du site de dano dire
avant que toute cette affaire un vide
nos qu il comptait qu'on n'a jamais eu
de compte à quelqu'un le pdg de
lanaudière
j'ai vérifié auprès de chefs connus mais
légalement shawinigan maillot lehmann
contact avec la fédé vinicius lanaudière
lorsqu'en plus consensuelle d'un buzz
wolof de salaire en plus de près de 2 et
qu'après il y ait de gouren des
situations à 2-0 désignant le bio matin
là comme si enviée il y avait commandé
une formation auprès du personnel
médical en décembre de l'accusation
la sécurisation thuel et c'est tous
aujourd'hui que vous me posez vos coups
qu'il était au courant qu'ils étaient au
courant qu'ils savaient pas comment cela
s'était passé
mais toutes les erreurs se faire mais il
faut voter aujourd'hui qu'il est
douloureux mais on peut facilement
oui d'ailleurs parlant de cette fameuse
formation en sécurisation culturel
jennifer il n'est pas passé par vous il
n'est pas passé par le cal pour vous
demandez peut-être de la mettre sur pied
on avait je sais qu'il y avait quelques
années il y avait eu des travaux entre
le cal qui le 6 pour développer un
programme de formation qui ait jamais
été mises en oeuvre je sais qu'il y
avait au courant des années par
informations qui ont été enfin mais qui
n'était pas étais c'était quelque chose
que vous est ce que c'était de base
volontaire qui on a vu qu est-ce qui a
sorti avait peut-être trois quatre
personnes qui ont participé prêtre c'est
par une autre alors c'était pas a priori
non plus pour les membres de l'équipe 1
au sein de ces institutions là à qui moi
j'ai une rencontre avec le pdg eux qui
étaient désignés en tant que responsable
schoten au sein du 6 en juin
où est ce que je lui la faible alertés
sur le fait qu on avait beaucoup d'anges
russie ou au cal
un travers nos manches avaient en valeur
leur système de santé qui sait pour ce
qu'on veut on a essayé de mettre en
place assez vite
le cynique de proximité alors si il veut
dire que je ne savais pas ça veut dire
même que sont son ajointe à un lieu pour
parler de cet enjeu là alors c'est soit
ils l'ont pas parlé parce qu'ils savent
que ce alors que celui intéresse pas ou
qu'il ya quelque chose d'autre qui se
met jamais ce qu'il va y en avoir une
formation qui va être donnée en bout de
ligne je pense à mes yeux
actuellement il y en a pas ce qu'en dit
web actuellement il ya un lion une
formation en sécurité culturelle de base
pour faire connaître la communauté
l'histoire un peu ce qui a été fait un
blog à 3 à l'ensemble des employés
qu'ils souhaitaient pourrait être
libérée yeux ça c'est fait
dernier les formations sont enregistrés
le sait sylvie roy qui est une
psychologue a tiqué merkel je crois
qu'elles viennent d'abidjan qui qui est
qui et qui la donnent l'information est
donc assez entrepris il ya aussi un
d'entre eux qui étaient donne à l'ucad
pour faire cette formation de fait
ensuite on peut discuter du double les
efforts bien peu
et moi j'ai pigé en sortant j'ai pas des
jets pas d'intérêt un homme et ça mais
ça risque
on a eu des contacts avec la direction
générale du stis et le on peut juger
comme on veut ce qui s'est passé le
présentement il ya quand même une
réactivité qui est présente
qu'est ce qui en sortira je pense qu'il
ya des gens qui sont clairement prêt à
bouger
puis il ya des actions notamment d'avoir
quelqu'un d'enfants responsables non
clair de responsable pour la gestion de
ces dossiers là une personne qui serait
issu de la communauté une volonté
d'ouverture on peut déplorer qu'elle est
peut-être pas été présente avant tout
aux pieds le honnêtement ce moment c'est
plus à moi d'en juger puis je pense que
des gens qui sont vraiment les usagers
ni patience qu'il ya maquillage et à
joliette en milieu urbain les patients
peuvent juger de l'inaction ou du manque
d'action de tout le monde de tous les
intervenants le à ce moment ci est ce
qu'on peut comme un combat avance là
dedans
j'ose croire que les gens sont sincères
quand ils existent sont prêts à bouger
puis à mettre les ressources pour ça
alors être arrivé bien avant on est
d'accord
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait maintenant deux
sur moi comme médecin je travaille déjà
avec avec mais résidant avec les
différents échelons à l'université à
faire des représentations auprès des
autres facultés avec mes collègues on
est en train de voir comment on va faire
la formation partenariat justement pour
que les réalités ce soit connue puisque
les gens à mende leur conduite
réellement soit il poursuit ensuite
beaucoup de travail politique qui on
n'entendait plus des bus qui reste à
faire mais bon ça va avoir pris un décès
pour arriver ja c'est extraordinairement
triste mais j'ose croire que dans
quelques années dit si on veut pouvoir 0
enfants de jaws qu'on était à là
donc on pense qu'on va avoir fait ce
qu'il fallait c'est comme comme comme
groupe comme organisation on l'a déçu
souvent je pense le jour je crois qu'on
va faire différemment puis j'espère
qu'il ya encore un peu de confiance que
ça va pouvoir se refaire clé c'est
fragile et vous vous avez dit pour les
gens qui souhaitaient donc une formation
qui va être donnée pour les gens qui le
souhaitent est ce que ça va donner pour
les gens qui le souhaitent ou ça va être
donné à tous obligatoirement c'est ça le
sport
faudrait voir libérer le mais
honnêtement les toute participation
était très bon ensuite le texte exact il
faudrait platement que vous alliez voir
les réussissent là pour vous qu'est-ce
que ça en est mais ce qu'ils veulent
pour le oui non je comprends je
comprends mais je comprends aussi
l'inquiétude de jennifer qui se dit on
veut pas qu'ils aient 3 4 5 ou 7
personnes dans une formation il faut que
tout le monde assiste à la formation
je suis dans les quelque chose aussi il
ya le plus de changements qui devraient
se penser que juste la formation la
formation c'est important par contre
l'infirmière raciste qui m'a traité
jouer à cette hauteur là je pense pas
qu'une formation aurait changé trop ses
pensées - quel organe national
quand on perd un système et on peut le
démontrer par le fait qu' il faut avoir
un inondations de déploration de de
l'enjeu avant que yoann action à chaque
fois ça se passe avec les femmes
autochtones
il faut avoir des milliers de femmes
autochtones décédé e julie ou disparus
avant que j'ai pris au sérieux
non il faut combien de personnes ici
pour qu'il y ait des actions concrètes
aux cons bouche ou qu'il fasse qu'est ce
qu'ils auraient dû faire déjà sa prise
doit quoi donc qui va se reprendre dans
la cueillir des vrais changements au
sein de cette institution là moi je veux
pas attendre un ou deux ans
voilà alors je reviens maintenant donner
ou redonner confiance aux autochtones
envers le système de santé je pense
qu'il va falloir donner cette confiance
là constant vous avez entendu jennifer
vous avez du travail
maintenant vous allez vous tourner et
retourner vers les politiciens en poste
à québec je pense que vous avez beaucoup
vous aussi de travail à faire pour que
les choses changent
pascal vous aussi en tant que médecin il
ya beaucoup de travail qui doit être
fait je sais que vous en faites beaucoup
à vous avez quoi plus de 500 patients
que vous soyez un manouane vous les
appliquez avec vous les connaissez vous
connaissez la réalité vous faites
justement de l'enseignement à
l'université avec la sécurisation
culturel vous la fait cette sécurisation
culturel avec avec les futurs médecins
et je pense qu'elle doit continuer et
puis jennifer mettre votre côté avec ce
que vous faites à la casse en d'amitié
autochtone de lanaudière
il a aussi il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire pour conscientiser entre
légendes à joliette entre autres qui
doivent changer à l'hôpital de joliette
les relations vous avez je pense hier l
énorme travail en silo et et habib sow
côté marrant merci merci beaucoup à tous
les trois d'avoir participé à cette
émission
alors jennifer brazeau directrice
générale du centre d'amitié autochtone
de lanaudière docteur pascal braud avec
attaché au projet mf donc au groupe de
médecine familiale universitaire de
lanaudière merci beaucoup pour votre
travail
et puis grands schémas constant awashish
du conseil national d éthique avec merci
à tous les trois et j'espère qu'on va
pouvoir continuer cette conversation
bientôt en voyant que finalement les
changements se sont installés on
l'espère tous
[Musique]